if you missed your chance to try out the  uncharted 4 multiplayer beta back in  December it looks like you may have  another shot a PlayStation Store listing  reportedly popped up today stating that  the beta would be held march forth until  the 6th this posting has since been  removed but not before neogaf captured  the details if the listing on the German  PlayStation Store is accurate than the  beta will offer 3 maps and a team  deathmatch mode it is unclear if the  beta will be the same as the closed one  but chances are it'll be very similar  the first beta was held last year but it  was only available to those who picked  up uncharted than Nathan Drake  collection at the time naughty dog had  no plans for another beta but it seems  like things may have changed Naughty Dog  is yet to confirm this beta but we have  reached out to Sony in an attempt to get  more details if we find out more you'll  be the first to know